redondea 9.564 a decimos y para ello voy
a volver a escribir este número vamos a
ponerlo en grande 9 punto
4 donde tenemos aquí enteros o unidades
y de este lado tenemos los décimos
centésimos y milésimos
ahora nos están diciendo redondea 9.564
mil decimos a decimos los décimos se
encuentran en esta posición
podemos redondear hacia dos opciones
hacia arriba donde 9.564 quedarían 9.6 o
hacia abajo donde quedaría como 9.5 de
que depende si redondear hemos hacia
arriba o hacia abajo pues para saber eso
nos vamos a ubicar en el valor
posicional
siguiente o más pequeño en este caso
tenemos el 6 no estamos tomando el más
pequeño de todos estamos tomando el que
sigue al punto en que vamos a redondear
es decir si estamos redondeando a
decimos nos fijaremos en los centésimas
que es el valor posicional siguiente o
más pequeño
y vemos este 6 nos indicará si
redondeamos hacia arriba o hacia abajo
cuáles son las reglas si el número de
referencia llamémoslo x
es igual
o mayor que 5 es decir se 5 6 7 8 9
entonces ese valor redondear a hacia
arriba y si ese valor x
que tengamos como referencia es menor
que 5 es decir 43 2 o 1 entonces
redondear hemos hacia abajo
en este caso tenemos el 6 este 6 sin
duda es más grande que el 5 por lo que
si redondeamos nos quedará 9 punto
6 este 5 lo subimos hacia el siguiente
número que 6 y entonces esta será
nuestra respuesta
9.564 redondeado a decimos será igual a
9.6 y listo
tenemos nuestra respuesta nos vemos en
otro vídeo